yes
um for you man uh
I know a lot of people are doing collab
tapes collab albums recently well who
would you do a whole project with if you
could another artist that you haven't
worked with yet if I ever do a project
something I'm doing
I'm gonna do it with my cousin fur
everybody have you guys ever talked
about it yeah
plenty of time yeah you know would you
be boys and you feel that you know no
[__] what [__] really be pressuring
each other about no [__] I know you guys
just got a ton of unreleased music
together
yeah we're playing a little special back
in the day but [__] we got a whole bunch
of [__]
you keep those sessions if it's like a
2016 session is it somewhere
yeah like do you have just done
do you have hard drives in the safe
place though hey yeah you got to get it
safe gotta keep them safe
you can't let this [__] happen again
was that um
disheartening to have your music leak
and [__] hurt me how many songs were
there it was like two on them
[__] see what I'm saying can't let that
[__] happen again 200 songs because they
leak do you decide to not drop them at
all yeah I'll be like [__] that [__]
damn I already heard it so [__] I know
excitement for that [__] you know what
you gotta do then all I'm saying they
lead the [__] oh them [__] won't
even know them that's probably gonna
piss you off even more like this [__]
they were old and that was just one
producer
[Music]
you should drop them as like you know
not you know Nas the rapper now
obviously yeah he has the lost tape
Series so he'll put out like a bunch of
unreleased [__]
this Pokemon has best albums ever is the
first Lost Tapes but it was like a
compilation of songs that never came out
or Elite over like a 10-year period or
something right there they made good man
all that [__] it's a lot though I mean
bro you could put out a 200 song mixtape
but just Gucci so I think Gucci's last
album has like a [__] 78 songs on it
I don't know the last time I've listened
to 80 songs like
in a month
is that a lot that's what I'm saying I
don't see how the hell they're gonna how
the hell y'all gonna listen to him or
something yeah yeah you listen to
podcasts pug yeah like or interviews or
like you know it depends
what do you like to listen to people
talk about anime no it depends on where
going on in the world
or what somebody's saying or some [__] I
might want to go see they see what they
said in the podcast myself
so I can feel like I probably feel about
the situation type [__] you somebody
like someone said something about you
nah just in general to be speaking about
some [__] right now you might see
somebody to bash somebody on Instagram
they said oh he said that I go see what
he said yeah cause you can't just trust
the headline yeah yeah no you can't
never train no [__] like that that's
some real [__] [__] probably got now
who's speaking some real [__] [__] you
never uh said what your favorite anime
ever was man
I thought we were gonna run around that
[__] that [__] up
my favorite anime scent
I mean I feel like that was everybody
yeah like as a kid woman yeah Dragon
Ball was the one yeah yeah as a kid yeah
yeah but now my favorite anime probably
like
um
how'd you I fought with one punch man
that [__] oh what is the premise
my son watches that what's it about
there's no little is there anything I'm
trying to I'm trying to think
it's about getting punched once
let me Google it
one bunch
he basically like it like
I don't know because it's something for
his head on just straight just punch
like one punch out type [__] you know
what I'm saying but
like majority of all the people he
really get into it with
is it called one punch man yeah one
punch man
oh I see he's like a ball dude yeah he
ball here
this fool looks like [__]
this fool looks like goddamn he ain't
got no superpowers either
so we just oh look at him he's like a
nerdy dude yeah yeah
so why so is he he
trying to say I don't know how the [__]
he's trying to sell to be be got down
that goddamn so he's a super so it's
about a superhero who's normal
yeah like you're a human basically yeah
you ever watch The Boondocks The
Boondocks yeah yeah
Boondocks is amazing Boondock gonna
always be that [__]
two seasons of The Boondocks are good
the last season was a little because the
main Rider quit yeah man I like what's
your favorite character
I mean I love
I love Riley
I mean Gramps is funny uh
I like what's the racist black dude who
hates yeah I know who I like wait no
Uncle Ruckus I said Clayton Bixby that's
Dave spell scary Uncle Ruckus yeah I'll
go right here that probably is the
funniest [__] on that [__] Bro
now [__] stupid as hell he said
anything he don't give a damn hold on
bro Uncle Ruckus
I have so my best friend's brother works
on
you got to hear this drop
if I have it
this is the actual actor is this it hold
on hey America this is
and even though he dressed dressing on
like a donkey
to the greatest white man oh Lord they
smell like Financial polish and lemon
zest God bless his white skin
lick him
hey yes how to fight the hill man bro I
mean he'll [__] [__] but he fighting
him what was like because the guy who
voices a few of the characters include
Uncle Ruckus yeah he did a drop he was
doing radio drops and [__] so I was like
bro I need a Uncle Ruckus drop
when he was a little kid yes I see them
all that [__] was so goddamn funny boy
yeah I like uh I like the uh the the
episode where the the [__] lawyer
dude
his wife gets snatched by Usher
do you remember the episodes Usher
snatches this dude's [__] and then he
goes and hires a pimp named slickback to
try to get his girl back
is [__] hilarious by the way oh oh
the pimp
named slickback yeah I know the little
pimp with the pink with the little yeah
yeah I know that cat we didn't care but
yeah yeah the parent was funny they had
too oh so good man so good